Blue Moon, die zwei Sprechstunden.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1, los!
Du kannst dir von oben angucken, dass du auf einer Straßenecke stehst und auf dein Telefon guckst.
Das wäre dann noch die nächste Stufe, aber das kommt bestimmt auch bald. Aber das ist wirklich dann so wie im James Bond Film oder wie bei Night Rider. Das wünsche ich mir auch, dass ich irgendwie so eine komische Armanduhr habe, wo ich sage, Kid, fahr das Auto vor die Tür. Und das wäre nochmal so ein Yes erhebend.
James Bond ist ein gutes Stichwort.
Da sind auch tolle Sachen dabei.
Da sind immer solche Sachen drin. Genau diese Sachen, er steht irgendwo in der Pampa mit seinem Auto und dann hat er auf einmal so ein Navi-System in seiner Konsole und das zeigt genau mit Piep, Piep, Piep, Piep, wo er ist. Und ich weiß noch ganz genau, wie ich das als Kid gesehen habe und mir dachte so, was denn das für ein Scheiß, das funktioniert ja überhaupt nicht.
Dafür gibt es überhaupt gar keine Infrastruktur.
Ich hatte vollkommen recht, was den damaligen Zustand betrifft, aber so, ich weiß nicht, so richtig drüber nachgedacht, dass das nicht mehr so weit weg sein könnte, habe ich nicht. Also so Satelliten. Ich glaube, ich habe es eher für unmöglich gehalten in dem Moment.
Es gab ja, und damals sind wir bei Bond-Filmen ein schönes Thema, es gab ja auch einen dieser, ich glaube, das war Moonraker oder Goldfinger, einer von denen, die irgendwie alle Woche mal wiederholt werden, wo Leute in so eine, wie so ein Kleiderwagen, bei so Interhotels, bei großen Hotels, sich so reinstellen, also wie so eine Schubkarre mit so einem Gerüst oben drüber, da sind zwei Raketen hinten dran, die kannst du ziehen, damit kannst du ein Stückchen fliegen. So was gibt es ja auch, so was ist ja wirklich gebaut und getestet worden. Das war ja kein Schnickschnack, den die sich da ausgedacht haben. Nicht, dass ich mich jemals darum reißen würde, mit so einem Ding irgendwie durch die Gegend zu fliegen. Aber es ist schon abgefahren, was da gebaut wird. Aber James Bond auch nur am Rande als Thema. Wir kommen jetzt zu was, wo ich weiß, dass Tim sich total drüber freut. Nämlich der Anruf von Daniel, wenn er sein Radioliser macht. Hallo Daniel.
Ja, nee, das war das Telefon, hatte ich auf freisprechend.
Daniel, wenn auf meinem Monitor, was da steht, wenn das stimmt, wenn du mir das jetzt erzählst, dann freue ich mich auf die Geschichte.
Also das hat mich... Ja, meine heulte Mutter...
Warte mal, pass auf, du bist die Alten, kommst wo her?
Ich bin 24 und komme aus Wolmestädt, das ist in der Nähe von Magdeburg. Ja, also Rand des Fritzinde-Gebietes. Willkommen, so. Ja, meine heulte Mutter hat mich dazu verdonnert, Rasen zu mähen, dabei hatte ich mich an dem Tag gerade so übergefreut, dass mein neuer Router gekommen war, mit WLAN. Ja, und dann habe ich mit dem halt so ein bisschen rumgespielt und ich bin als, darf ich jetzt sagen, iPhone-Hasser, das kann mein Telefon jetzt schon alles, das meiste. Also jetzt war ganz grob. Halt mit WLAN ausgerüstet, vom Telefon her. Und habe dann, damit ich das Rasenmien natürlich auch genießen kann, von meinem Rechner MP3s über meinen WLAN, was er gerade schön eingerichtet hat, auf mein Telefon gestreamt, damit ich MP3s von meinem PC über meinem Telefon beim Rasenmien hören kann. Ja, und das war so, also ich stand dann so im Garten, hörte so meine MP3s, die ich so gerade bei Winamp reingemacht habe, und dachte so, ja, das ist ganz schön technisch. Das ist schon so richtig, ja, also wenn das so weitergeht, dann wird es nur noch besser eigentlich.
Ja, ja, das sind diese schönen Dekadenten-Installationen. Wenn man nur so ein bisschen die Technik im Griff hat, dann kann man irgendwie auch, vor allem wenn man mal zusammenrechnet, was du da sozusagen für einen Warenwert irgendwie zusammengekratzt hast, nur um mal ein bisschen Musik beim Rasenmien zu hören, ist auch schon erstaunlich. Du hättest die sowieso gekauft, von daher ist ja vollkommen okay.
Das Schlimme ist ja eigentlich, es ist eine super komplexe technische Lösung, aber mein Handy hat einen MP3-Player, also auf das Vorspulen der Titel verzichte ich bewusst. Also ich kann dann, oh jetzt habe ich einen falschen Titel in der Playlist, kann ich nicht weitermachen, weil ich streame es ja gerade von meinem PC auf mein Handy. Ja, das werde ich dann wahrscheinlich demnächst machen. Jetzt ist ja Winter, jetzt mal gucken.
Musst du im Winter auch Rasen nehmen?
Nee, aber ich sehe Daniel im Winter quasi im Schuppen verschwinden, wirst du mit einer Thermoskanne Tee und einem Stift hinter dem Ohr und dann so, ich zeichne hier mal noch so ein Modell, mal gucken, ob das geht. Dann kommen irgendwelche abgefahrenen Dinger raus und im nächsten Frühjahr sitzt Daniel, ich wette sitzt Daniel zu Hause, hört seine MP3s mit Füßen auf den Tisch und der Rasenmäher fährt von alleine.
Ja, das wäre das beste dann.
Du würdest ein Programm schreiben, wo du deinen Rasenmäher, den Garten gescannt hast und den Rasenmäher vom Bildschirm aus durch den Garten dirigierst.
Na ja, raus soll es schon gehen. Man ist ja im Rahmen des WLAN auch fähig, sich auch neben den Rasenmäher zu setzen und sich an der wirklichen Effizienz seiner Programmiertätigkeit zu erfreuen.
Die einfache Variante ist, du suchst dir jemand, der diesen Rasenmäher für dich schiebt, du läufst einfach hinten her und hörst Musik.
Aber groß hat man einfach einen Ghetto Blaster genommen und die komplette Kolonie beschallt.
Ja, das ist eigentlich das Schlimme. Es gibt eigentlich so viele, viel einfache Lösungen. Aber das ist auch eine Sache, da hat es mich so richtig geflasht.
Genau, manchmal sind nämlich die richtig dekadenten Installationen erst die richtig cool.
Es gibt da eine Formulierung und die trifft genau zu zwischen Ghetto Blaster und ich streame mir meine MP3s auf meinen Rasenmäher. Das eine ist sportlich, das andere nicht.
Super Geschichte, da fällt mir auch gleich noch was zu ein.
Danke Daniel.
Schönen Abend euch Leute.
Nächster Anruf.
Welche Anrufe haben wir denn da noch?
Im Moment können wir mit Markus reden, mit Rady reden.
Du bist auch immer mit der C.
Sie redet sowieso immer so viel.
Hallo Markus.
Willst du das Tim was erzählen oder willst du was erzählen?
Lass doch erstmal den Tim zu sagen.
Heißt Servus, dass du aus Österreich anrufst?
Ja bitte, ich wohne in Hessen.
Er ist ja auch ziemlich weit weg. Und du hörst uns über was?
Über Webstream. Also im Moment über das Telefon.
Okay, über welchen Webstream?
Über unseren oder den von Fritz?
Okay, super.
Das ist ein Gruß an die Fangemeinde, die sich immer fleißig kümmert, dass ordentlich gestrebt wird.
Ja, ich bin auch sehr dankbar. Okay, also, einmal los. Mein Name ist DeMarcus, ich bin 24 und mich flash Peer to Peer. Also, die meisten werden es von uns benutzen, denke ich mal. Aber ich kann jetzt nicht genau festmachen, wann das angefangen hat. Das wurde natürlich durch die ganzen Flat Rates immer einfacher und durch Breitband natürlich auch. Aber einen Moment habe ich vor ein paar Wochen im Kopf irgendwie, da schickte mir ein Kumpel so ein YouTube Video von diesen berühmten Teaser-Girls, die sich dann immer so mit ihren Brüsten beschäftigen. Das kennt jeder. Ich nicht. Und da war dann irgendein Song zu hören, den er nicht kannte, aber unbedingt haben wollte. Also ich lasse jetzt mal die ganze Copyright-Diskussion außen vor. Er schickte mir also den Titel von diesem Lied und innerhalb von fünf Minuten hatte ich das Lied gefunden und ihm zugemailt von einer Band, von der ich noch nie was gehört hatte, von der er noch nie was gehört hatte. Wir heißen wie? Ach, das muss ich raussuchen, das ist lange her. Auf jeden Fall, also das ist eben das, was mich an Peer to Peer so freut sozusagen. Also ich komme an alles dran, mir erzählt jemand was von einem Film, von irgendeinem Lied, von irgendeiner Band, was auch immer und ich brauche jetzt nicht zu suchen, ob ich da eine Platte aus den 70er Jahren irgendwo in einem kleinen Laden finde, sondern ich kann im Internet gucken und sagen, zack, ach innerhalb von fünf Minuten habe ich das auf der Platte, kannst du mir anhören.
Aber mit Peer to Peer meinst du jetzt eher dein Kommunikationsmodell, wie du mit den Leuten redest, nicht so sehr, wo die das Teilen herkriegen.
Ja eigentlich, ja natürlich. Es geht eigentlich eher darum, dass die Leute kommunizieren und sich das Zeug über die Technologie gegenseitig bereitstellen können. Also ich benutze im Moment dieses tolle Programm Miro, das kennen vielleicht einige, um so Screencasts irgendwie zu verdichten sozusagen. Und das ist halt für mich, das war ein extremer Flash, als ich das vor ein paar Wochen gefunden habe. Weil das einfach die Zukunft des Fernsehens sozusagen ist. Ich kriege mir da meine Sendungen zusammen, die ich mir gerne angucken möchte. Und ich kriege die von anderen Leuten ins Haus reingeliefert sozusagen. Kannst du mir angucken ohne TiWO, ohne gar nichts.
Du musst vielleicht nochmal Werbung machen. Miro heißt das Ding. getmiro.com Und das ist einfach ein ganz ganz einfacher Video Player, womit man so Video Feeds, also quasi regelmäßige Veröffentlichungen abonnieren kann.
Genau.
So was wie Podcasts, aber eben mit Video. Und das ist super einfach zu bedienen, rockt einfach total, funktioniert prima. Kann ich schwer empfehlen.
Gibt es für Linux, Mac und für Windows und funktioniert. Also es gibt auch die öffentlich-rechtlichen Namen, zum Beispiel ZDF, Treisat und so weiter. Die stellen auch teilweise ihre Sachen als Podcast rein. Das kann man sich alles runterladen, alles mit dem Programm. Das ist halt wirklich wie ein RSS-Feed und das ist also für mich auch ein Teil von dieser ganzen Peer-to-Peer-Geschichte, weil man damit einfach viel schneller an seine Sachen rankommt und auch an Sachen rankommt, die man niemals vorher irgendwie gehabt hätte oder keine Möglichkeit. Also wenn ich mir jetzt von einem Freund erzählen lasse, dass die und die Band ein gutes Lied geschrieben hat und ich müsste jetzt erstmal in die Bahn steigen und in meinen örtlichen kleinen Plattenladen fahren, bei uns auf dem Dorf gibt es leider keinen, und da eine Stunde im Regal rum suchen oder dem möglicherweise noch peinlich vorsummen, wie dieses Lied jetzt funktioniert, da gehe ich ins Netz, gebe den Titel ein oder gehe auf, wie heißt das, Zongsa oder sowas, gibt es auch noch Suchmaschinen, und habe das Lied innerhalb von 10 Minuten. Gut, man kann sich jetzt darüber streiten, ob man dafür bezahlen will oder nicht.
Das könnte jetzt sehr lange führen, aber die Diskussion führen wir jetzt mal an der Stelle nicht, ohne das in irgendeiner Form zu werten. Aber du hast schon recht, dass diese, ob jetzt peer-to-peer oder allgemein, diese beständige Verfügbarkeit von schnellem Internet, was ja eigentlich immer da ist mittlerweile, sehr viel Kommunikation einfacher macht, sehr viel Recherche einfacher macht und auch Leute, die in infrastrukturell entlegenen Gebieten wohnen, ihnen trotzdem die Möglichkeit gibt, ganz schnell und ganz fix mit anderen Leuten zu kommunizieren, wie die Geschichte, die Tim erzählt hat, aus New Orleans mit Katrina, dass man da über einen Chat mit Leuten, die auf der anderen Seite der Welt sind, ganz schnell zack, zack, zack kommunizieren kann.
Wenn sie denn DSL haben oder einen schnellen Internetzugang.
Ja, aber auch allein die Fülle der Informationen, die ich damit abgreifen kann. Also ich kann mich ja immer nur bei einem Laden oder bei irgendeinem Kaufhaus darauf verlassen, dass der Einkäufer sich jetzt gerade dafür entschieden hat, diese CD mit ins Programm zu nehmen. Oder ich muss aus den USA irgendwie ordern für 30 Dollar Versandgebühren. Per Peer to Peer gehe ich auf einen Direktvertrieb von dem jeweiligen Label oder von dem jeweiligen Künstler. Und hab das dann einfach. Da hängt natürlich die ganze Infrastruktur mit einem Breitbandnetz dran. Aber allein, dass es diese Angebote gibt, dass ich mir aussuchen kann, also ich mir wirklich selber aussuchen kann, was ich mir denn jetzt angucken will und nicht immer abhängig davon bin, dass jemand für mich so eine Vorauswahl trifft. Also das ist für mich die Zukunft, sag ich.
Ja, da hab ich vielleicht nochmal einen Tipp, vielleicht für dich und auch alle anderen. Es gibt so eine coole Film, wie soll man das nennen? Man müsste es Fernsehserien nennen, es lief bloß nie im Fernsehen, sondern im Internet. Es heißt The Scene. Und handelt von eben dieser Rare Szene, wo halt so Filme früh gerippt werden und so weiter. Und das ist eine total absurde Situation, weil die da einfach 90% der Zeit wird überhaupt nicht geredet, sondern sie sind einfach nur am Chatten. Und man sieht halt, was da auf dem Desktop läuft und so. Das ist extrem spannend. The Scene heißt das einfach. Kann man irgendwie schnell über Wikipedia finden, das ist halt so eine Miniserie. Also welcome to thescene.com ist die URL. Da findet man das 1000 Formaten natürlich auch über peer to peer.
Chaosradio 130, Living The Future 0331 70 97 11.
Hast du dir schon eine Living The Future Geschichte erzählt?
Ich überlege die ganze Zeit, welche der vielen Living The Future Geschichten ich erzählen sollte. Was mich wirklich immer, was mich sehr geflasht hat, war die ganze WLAN Geschichte. Also dass man nicht mehr an einem Schreibtisch sitzen muss und da am Computer sitzen muss.
Den Moment, würde ich sagen.
Du klappst den Rechner irgendwo auf, fährst ihn hoch und weißt, okay, machst du einen Browser, okay, du lädest eine Seite aus dem Cache. Und dann gibst du irgendeine Seite eine, der macht, ne, ne, ne, ne, Spiegelonline ist da. Irgendwo mitten unter einem Baum auf einer Wiese. Leucht's noch Saft? Das hat mich echt begeistert, weil ich bin jemand, der hat so, ich mag so MacGyver Gadgets, also so Dinger, die multifunktional sind, so der typische Letterman-Ausprobierer. Braucht man nie, aber ist immer toll, so was zu haben. Und alles, was irgendwie mich nicht zu Hause fesselt, wo ich also entscheiden kann, was, wo und wie ich das machen will, total spannend, Mobiltelefon, Walkman, MP3-Player, was auch immer, Musik mit in die Welt nehmen und irgendwo das da machen und nicht irgendwo hinrennen müssen und dann umsitzen und warten, das hat mich echt geflasht.
Also ich finde auch so WLANs, das ist Wahnsinn, so Wireless LANs. Das war mein erstes Erlebnis, das war bei uns auf dem CCC-Camp vor, was haben wir jetzt?
99, acht Jahre her.
Acht Jahre her, zack, so eine Karte rein, irgendwie bei 40 Grad auf dem Acker, irgendwie eine grüne Wiese, wo sonst irgendwie Pferde grasen.
Du warst einer von zehn oder so, ne?
Es waren nicht so viele Leute, es waren damals so die ersten Karten gerade, es war auch mal ein Experiment, wir wussten auch noch gar nicht, wir dachten, naja, vielleicht ist wieder so eine komische Technik, die wieder in einem Jahr verschwunden ist und so. Dann haben wir mal so ein Netzwerk aufgebaut, und es war auch großartig, zack, Karte rein, kurz installiert, mal eben schnell, wie das halt so ist. Aber es hat dann irgendwie funktioniert. Ja, dann gab es da irgendwie Internet, man konnte man rumlaufen, man konnte das Ding irgendwie mit zum See runternehmen, man konnte damit irgendwie abends Pizza essen gehen, da auf dem Camp und alles. Man hat einfach sein Internet dabei gehabt, das ist großartig.
Ja, ich glaube, umso mobiler das Internet, umso mehr Zukunft. So, ich meine, wir haben ja hier vorhin vor der Sendung auch irgendwie noch dieses eine Liedchen, was wir noch einspielen werden, so, ja, Scheiße, wo kriegen wir denn das jetzt her? Frank irgendwie zu Hause auf seinem Rechner, gab natürlich noch kein WLAN, also zack, UMTS-Büchse rausgezogen über Bluetooth. Also ja, erstmal kommt das Internet über UMTS ins Telefon, geht über Bluetooth in den Rechner, dann zieht man sich das Pfeil, konvertiert es noch, schickt es dann wiederum per E-Mail raus, irgendwie damit es jetzt hier im Studio lande, damit wir hier auf Knopf drücken können. Das ging aber. Jetzt muss ich spielen. Ja, was war das für eine Scheiße vor irgendwie, was weiß ich, 10 Jahren, als wir mit Chaos Radio angefangen haben?
12.
Chaos Radio ist jetzt übrigens 12 Jahre her. Genau.
Ziemlich genau, ja.
Fällt mir gerade so ein.
Ta-dam.
Ta-dam. 12 Jahre Chaos Radio.
Auspusten.
Genau.
Das war's im Jahre 1993. Fischmop unter der Leitung von Bollesnüther, Dänemark. Und now back to the 60s zu den 64ern und dem nächsten Mörderwurm. Hallo, ich wünsch mir Frogger von der Gruppe Atari.
Ich hab ja einfach mal aus der Kalten so einen Song rausgehauen, und alle so boah, was ist das denn, ey, was ist das denn, ey?
Was soll wir haben? Spax oder Spex aus Braunschweig.
Toller Rapper, lange Zeit, also weniger Musik gemacht in der letzten Zeit, weil ein Großteil vom Hip-Hop sich ja damit beschäftigt hat, entweder sich zu erzählen, dass der andere Scheiße ist, oder aber, dass dein Auto 21 Zoll Felgen hat, und das andere hat 22 Zoll Felgen, und deswegen ist die Kiste besser. Und jetzt kommt Spex um die Ecke und hat diese wunderbare Jill Scott-Heron-Version gemacht, die jetzt auch mal Spiele Revolution, gibt es nur als Demo und bei Fritz zu hören. Ihr seid im Chaosradio 130, Telefon 0331-7797 einsetzen.
So live wie die Revolution.
Da ist nichts abgesprochen.
Das ist jetzt nicht ein toller Untertitel.
Wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ich kratze hier am Mikro, dann ist live.
Alles.
Kratz mich überhaupt nicht.
Und?
Machen wir's jetzt.
Ja, Zukunft, wa? Hast du noch eine? Wer ist denn als nächstes dran? Frank. Erzähl doch mal eine Zukunftsgeschichte.
Wir hatten noch, wir haben ja noch am Telefon.
Wir haben noch so viele.
Rausgeflogen.
Brüning ist rausgeflogen.
Aber dann sollten wir vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz sagen was zu Frogger, weil das hat ja auch noch ein bisschen.
Das ist die Atari Nummer, die wir vorhin hatten.
Atari Nummer und das war eine Datasette. Und zwar, das sind ja Kassetten gewesen, wo man Daten, Programme drauf gespeichert hat, wie heute auf einer, auf einer Diskette oder.
Das war im Prinzip ein Akustikkoppler für Band.
Ja, oder halt wie eine, wie eine Diskette, die man auf dem Schallplattenspieler legen konnte oder so.
Wir fragen mal.
Das ist ja so cool, diese Idee, dass man sich im Radio Software wünscht und dann wird sie einfach so direkt ausgestrahlt. Und das Interessante ist, dass es das gab. Und zwar, man höre und staune natürlich nicht in Westdeutschland, sondern in der DDR wurde das gemacht. In dieser REM-Radiosendung haben die doch tatsächlich Programme für den KC-85 oder andere Modelle live ausgestrahlt. Hast du das live? Bist du eigentlich...
Wo kommst du eigentlich her? Oztler.
Oztler, wa? Hast du gehört? Hast du nicht gehört?
Ich hab nicht gehört. Du musst dich immer schön House of Hero machen.
Hast du keinen Homecomputer gehabt?
Nee, aber aha. Warte mal, erstmal greife ich in die Telefonleistung und sage schön guten Abend. Wer ist denn da?
Hallo?
Sorry, ich hatte in der Warteschleife gehört, dass noch zwei vor mir dran waren.
Das Internet, das spricht zu uns.
Du heißt wie?
Christoph, ich bin 26 und komme aus Siegen.
Wow, aus Siegen?
Genau.
Und du hörst uns wie?
Normalerweise übers Stream und jetzt gerade übers Telefon.
26, hast du von diesen ominösen Datasetten, die die Opis gerade erwähnt haben, hast du davon schon mal was gehört?
Ja, gut, das könnte natürlich auch ein Flash gewesen sein. Wenn ich damals bei meiner Oma war, da hatte mein Onkel ein C64 und die anderen Kisten alle da stehen. Und da hab ich also die Wochenende freiwillig für meine Oma verbracht, um in dieses Zimmer zu können. Und dann auch, ja, doch das ist tatsächlich auch ein Flash, wie es dann nachher durch die Cd-Rom und alles schneller wurde, weil ich erinnere mich an Batman auf dem C64, hatte eine Ladezeit von 40 Minuten.
Was hat man in der Zeitung?
Und wenn meine Oma der Zeitung kapte, musste ich vor ins Bett. Dann konnte ich das nicht mehr spielen, obwohl das gerade eben erst geladen war.
Dann muss die erste Floppy-Disc die Erleuchtung für dich gewesen sein. Wo das dann alles nur noch zwei Minuten gedauert hat.
Das war krass, das war so schnell. Da haben 170 Kilobyte draufgepasst.
Ja, aber Floppy-Disc hab ich übersprungen. Also meine Freunde hatten alle so einen C64, aber ich hab dann so einen Amiga bekommen, und da war das etwas noch schneller, ganz leicht. Außerdem war die Grafik besser.
Und da gab es dann gleich Festplatten.
Du hast die Disketten komplett übersprungen, richtig?
Mein eigentlicher Flash war, als eben der P2P-Anrufer dran war, da ist mir das wieder eingefallen, dass ich irgendwann mal, als ich meinen Eltern, als ich noch zu Hause gewohnt habe, versucht habe zu erklären, wie toll das Internet ist und was man alles machen kann, damit mich ganz weit aufs Fenster gelehnt haben gesagt. Man kriegt einfach die ganze Musik, die es auf der Welt gibt, auch über den Computer.
Und dann hat Papa gesagt, pass mal auf, es gab irgendwann von Peter Müller den Song Erdbeereis.
So ungefähr, es war etwas schlimmer. Er ist direkt runter in seinen Keller und hat von seinem alten Tonbandgerät so ein Lederbüchstein geholt, wo er dann so die ganzen Tonbänder mit Spurenummern und so eingetragen hat, wie jeder drauf war. Und sagte, hol mal, die krieg ich nicht. Weil egal, in welcher Stadt er ist, geht er immer in CD-Läden und guckt nach seiner Art Songs, das sind so One-Hit-Wonder aus den 50ern. Und dann fing das an, als ich irgendwie noch 4 Stunden Gus Bakus, der Mann im Mond auf meinem Rechner hatte, da war der gute Mann so begeistert von, dass er mich 2 Wochen lang in mein Zimmer eingesperrt hat, gesagt, Telefon ist jetzt mal egal.
Hier, Quatsch nicht, Quatsch nicht, mach, wenn du was zu essen willst, klopfst du an die Tür.
Vorher hieß es immer, blockier nicht die Telefonalterung, das zum Kotzen, wir schaffen das Internet wieder ab. Aber da war es auch einmal ganz okay. Und was mich einfach wirklich fasziniert hat, war, dass ich nach zwei Wochen seine Jugend irgendwie über meine kleine Kiste reingekriegt hab. Das fasziniert mich heute noch.
Plötzlich war das Internet der Freund von deinem Papa?
Ich hatte das auch, als ich angefangen hab, meine alte Musikkassettensammlung aufzulösen und einfach nach und nach reingehört hab, was ist es? Denn teilweise hast du nicht mal so sorgfältig aufgeschrieben, was es eigentlich ist. Man guckt im Internet nach, irgendwie Songtexte-Sammlung gibt da einen kurzen Teil vom Refrain ein.
Die RIAS-2-Moderatoren haben da immer schön hinten drauf gequatscht auf meine Kassetten.
Aber ich hab das ja richtig sauber alles aufgenommen. Ja, und dann nach und nach, eine Kassette nach der anderen, wanderte dann auch in den Müll, weil die Sachen tatsächlich übers Netz da waren. Das heißt, ich hab sie gefunden und auch natürlich bekommen übers Netz. Und das ist großartig. Das stimmt, das kann ich bestätigen. Also jetzt sag ich mal, vom Flash-Faktor jetzt nicht mehr so hoch, aber das finde ich auch schon mal eine ordentliche Errungenschaft.
Ich weiß noch, was das angefangen hat. Da kam ein Kollege zu mir und sagte hier, es gibt jetzt was ganz Neues zur Musik, das ist die Wave nur mit Zit und ich so, äh, wozu braucht man das?
Ich hab so eine Steheranlage.
Dann hatte ich auch anderthalb Jahre lang zwei MP3s. Das eine war diese Man in Black-Zitte-Song. Ja, und irgendwas, ich glaub XLF.
Klar, XLF.
Diese zwei MP3s und wenn ich mir heute überlege, was ich so auf meiner Platte hab an Musik.
Alleine, wie du das erzählst, da gibt es einen Wave als Zip-Down-Fahrt. Ich hab doch eine Serienanlage. Da hatte ich zwei MP3s. Die kriegen dann auch einzelne Namen. Man muss immer mal gucken, wie es ihnen geht. So ein bisschen wie das Tamagotchi. Schöne Geschichte.
Ja, damals hat das immer auch gedauert. Also meine erste CD, die ich gerippt hab, glaube ich, die war über Nacht. Also da war so ein MP3 auf meinem Pentium. 120, irgendwie 60 Minuten oder so. Also das hat noch echt Zeit gefressen damals.
Respekt. Schönen Gruß an den Papa und ich hoffe, dass du dir dieses Jahr für Weihnachten schon eine super, fuchser Jahre Oldiesampler zusammengestellt hast. Schönen Gruß nach Siegen. Wir machen gleich weiter im Chaosradio. 0331 77 97 110. Vorher die Nachrichten.
Kenfm.de Vier Stunden, drei Bands, ein Sonntag. Die vier Stunden sind klar. 14 bis 18 Uhr. Die drei Bands heißen Amos Live, A Song, A Cigarette und Gods of Blitz. Und der ein Sonntag, also der ist ja schon Ende der Woche. Vier Stunden, drei Bands, ein Sonntag. Fehlt nur noch die zwei.
Gott bewahre uns vor Halbidioten.
Kenfm.de Die Fritz-Radio-Show mit Ken Jepsen.
Immer sonntags ab 14 Uhr live in den Fritz-Studios in Potsdam-Wabelsberg.
Auf allen Frequenzen von...
Und das hört man...
Halb zwölf. Mit Matthias Zachow.
In der neuen PISA-Studie schneiden deutsche Schüler offenbar besser ab als in den vergangenen Jahren. Eine spanische Lehrerzeitung berichtete, sie liegen beim Umweltwissen und der Naturwissenschaften in der Spitzengruppe. Sie sind nämlich auf Platz 13 von insgesamt 57 Staaten. Bei der PISA-Studie 2003 war Deutschland noch auf Platz 18. Allerdings kann man beide Tests nicht vergleichen, weil die Aufgabenstrukturen anders sind. Nach der gestrigener Ostkonferenz in Annapolis haben US-Präsident Bush, Palästinenser Präsident Abbas und der israelische Ministerpräsident Olmert heute im Weißen Haus symbolisch die neuen Friedensverhandlungen gestartet. Gestern war vereinbart worden, dass die detaillierten Verhandlungen am 12. Dezember beginnen sollen. Die arabische Liga rief dazu auf, den neuen Friedensverhandlungen eine Chance zu geben. Mit einem Bußgeldkatalog wollen Bund und Länder den Jugendschutz verbessern. Wer Tabak, Alkohol oder Gewaltvideos an Jugendliche verkauft, muss in Zukunft mit bis zu vierstelligen Geldstrafen rechnen. Das sagte Bundesfamilienministerin von der Leyen heute. In Gaststätten und Tankstellen soll es Schwerpunktkontrollen geben. Die umstrittenen Testkäufe von Jugendlichen will die Ministerin nicht mehr bundesweit regeln. Zum Fußball in der Champions League haben sowohl Werder Bremen als auch Schalke 04 ihre Chancen auf die nächste Runde gewahrt. Bremen gewann gegen den spanischen Meister Real Madrid 3 zu 2. Schalke spielte in Valencia 0 zu 0 unentschieden. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Frankfurt 0 Grad, Potsdam Cottbus und Angermünde 1 Grad, Neuropin und Wittenberge 2 Grad und auch in Berlin 2 Grad momentan. Heute Nacht bleibt es trocken. Die Temperaturen sinken bis auf minus 4 Grad. Es kann glatt werden zum Teil. Morgen erst viele Wolken, nur ein bisschen Sonne zwischendurch. Zum Abend hin ist dann Regen oder Spülregen möglich. Die Temperaturen liegen morgen zwischen 3 und 6 Grad. Eine Meldung von der A12 Richtung Frankfurt-Odern. Zwischen Frankfurt Mitte und der Grenze steht ein kaputter Lkw. Hier gibt es Behinderungen, ansonsten euch überall eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Frankfurt Oder.
Brobeli Brobel, Chaosradio 130, Tim, Frank und Jakob im Studio 0331 70 97 110. Living The Future ist das Thema heute. Wir haben eine Menge fantastischer Geschichten gehört von euch zum Thema. Wann wart ihr Zeuge eines Momentes, wo ihr gesagt habt, das ist die Zukunft. Das ist, ich bin gerade Teil des MacGuywaschen. Du hattest vorhin diesen Highlander-Flash.
Genau, aber wo man es auch wirklich so lebt. Also wo man auch echt so das Gefühl hat, so jetzt bin ich irgendwie auch echt Teil davon. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt auch so ein paar Leute gehört, die meinen so, naja, ich habe jetzt so das Telefon, das ist ganz toll und so. Klar, das hat natürlich auch so diese Effekte, aber das hält immer nur so kurz an. Aber was mich immer so richtig fasziniert hat, ist, wenn ich das alles auch so richtig zur Anwendung gebracht habe. Aber wenn diese Geräte nicht nur toll sind und irgendwas versprechen, sondern wenn sie auch ihr Versprechen auch wirklich einlösen und wenn man auch ganz unerwartete Sachen macht. Also was ich zum Beispiel, was ich auch total cool fand, ist auch wieder so ein Erlebnis, was mit dem Chat anfing, irgendwie Maha hier auch aus dem Club, tauchte irgendwie so in meiner Buddyliste auf. Ich saß wieder gerade irgendwo gelangweilt rum zu Hause und sag ich so, Kling, Maha, online, den schnacke ich doch mal an, schon lange nicht mehr gesprochen. Na, altes Haus, was machst du denn und so. Ja, ich habe gerade New York verlassen und befinde mich jetzt irgendwie über dem Atlantik. Ups, also er saß halt mit seinem Laptop auf den Knien und hatte WLAN im Flugzeug. Das war jetzt dieses Connection by Boeing, also so Internet, was mittlerweile abgeschaltet ist, durch demnächst wirklich was Neues ersetzt wird. Und da gab es halt echt ganz gut Bandbreite. Das war wohl für Lufthansa ein bisschen zu teuer, aber sie haben es für relativ wenig Geld angeboten. Ich glaube, er hat so 20, 30 Euro bezahlt. Und ich so cool und so gleich irgendwie alle Tools rausgeholt und dann haben wir erst mal Skype gestartet und dann haben wir uns halt miteinander unterhalten. Also wir hatten richtig so eine Audio-Konferenz.
Wie war die Qualität?
Super. Also es war okay.
Hast du gemerkt, dass er im Flugzeug ist? Also irgendwie am Hintergrund, Rauschen, Brummen, irgendwie so?
Das ist eine gute Frage, aber das kann man selber überprüfen, weil jetzt wird es ja erst richtig cool, weil wir dann beschlossen haben, dann gleich über seinen USA-Urlaub, den er gerade beendet hat, einen Podcast zu machen. Außenflugzeug? Außenflugzeug. Das heißt, ich habe dann über Skype mit ihm einfach geredet, habe das irgendwie bei mir aufgezeichnet und dann waren wir irgendwie nach einer halben Stunde oder so, drei, vier Stunden, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, waren wir fertig, dann habe ich das irgendwie produziert, online gestellt und er hat dann den Podcast auch noch im Flugzeug mit seinem iTunes schon wieder runtergeladen.
Die Leute neben ihm haben bestimmt richtig blöde geguckt.
Der Typ neben ihm, das erzählt er auch irgendwie, glaube ich, in dem Podcast, der hatte irgendwie so ein Windows Laptop und der hat echt blöde geguckt.
Ja, wieso funktioniert denn das bei Ihnen alles so?
Das kenne ich ja gar nicht. Und das war auch wieder so ein Moment, wo ich mir dachte so, boah, wie cool, ja, irgendwie Internet im Flugzeug. Ich wusste den Zeitpunkt schon, dass so Skype-Telefonie ganz gut funktioniert mit der Anwendung, aber dass man das dann halt auch in dem Moment so live zum Einsatz bringt, dass einfach auch die Tools so gut funktionieren, dass man das zum Einsatz bringen kann, fand ich faszinierend. Das war irgendwie auch wieder so Zukunft jetzt hier.
Was ist denn die Frage an die Experten in der Runde? Wie lange wird es denn noch dauern, bis also drahtloses Internet so weit um uns herum ist überall, dass man sich nicht mehr irgendeinen Hotspot suchen muss und da hinrennt?
Das ist ja nur eine Frage der Kosten. Also mit UMTS, bei dem Probeefunkbreiber geht es ja. Es kostet halt nur noch ein Schweine Geld, das ist das Problem. Das Problem ist halt, es funktioniert auch nur so lange, wie es nicht alle nutzen, weil es ist natürlich nicht gut skaliert. Das heißt also, sobald viele Leute anfangen, diese ganzen UMTS-Dienste zu nutzen, ist das Netz auch ziemlich schnell wieder platt. Das heißt, man muss es irgendwie über den Preis regeln, dass es dann nicht doch so viele benutzen.
Es gibt ja diese ganzen technischen Erfindungen und Entwicklungen, von denen wir gerade gesprochen haben, tauchen natürlich immer bei dir als Pop-Flash neu und interessant auf, wenn man es braucht. Also wenn du wirklich gewühlt hast, du kannst damit irgendeine praktische Anwendung, du kannst gerade damit irgendwelche Dinge tun. Wenn nur dein Telefon oder dein Computer einen grünen Ball in einen blauen transformieren kann, dann ja, ok, schön ist es gewesen. Ich erinnere mich an ein Chaos Radio.
Sicher? Also du meinst, dass man irgendwie nur dann Technik annimmt, wenn sie für ein irgendwas Sinnvolles tut?
Nee, aber in dem Moment hast du, glaube ich, einen schnelleren Zugang dafür, wenn du sagen kannst, es hilft mir jetzt in irgendeiner Situation, in der ich was mache. Deinen Podcast mal außen vor. Lass mich mal ganz kurz den Gedanken zu Ende stellen. Also ich erinnere mich an das Chaos Radio zum Thema Global GPS Positioning System, also wie das GPS-System rund um die Welt funktioniert. Wo es darum ging, dass man mit einem relativ geringen Aufwand aus seinem Mobiltelefon ein Navigationsgerät machen kann und sich also diesen ganzen Navi-Blödsinn-Kram klemmen kann oder was extra kaufen muss. Und da sind wir wieder beim Thema Flächendeckendes Internet, worauf jeder zugreifen kann, was Frank ja gerade erklärt hat, wo das Problem dabei ist.
Also ja, diese ganze Telefontechnik finde ich schon gut, weil es ist natürlich auch recht robust. Und ich glaube, bei einem Telefon ist es dann auch noch mal eher einsichtiger für die anderen, wobei es natürlich auch so eine Sache ist, wie die Technik gewachsen ist. Also wenn ich überlege, vor zehn Jahren, wann war das so C-Netz, diese Riesentelefone, da haben mich meine ganzen Freunde schon ziemlich blöd angeguckt, wenn ich irgendwie ein Telefon dabei hatte, was gerade so nicht so ganz an meine Hosentasche gepasst hat. Natürlich heute undenkbar, oder was ich mir an so einem Gurt über die Schulter gehangen habe. Ich hatte später dann das SEM. Das war so das erste Handy in dem Sinne. Das war ungefähr so ein Viertel von einem Schuhkarton ungefähr. Also eher so vom Backstein-Format.
Du meinst das dicke, das Porti?
Nee, das Porti war das Pocky. Das Pocky ist glaube ich das Kleine.
Das Pocky hatte so Ziegelstein-Format.
Genau, das Ziegelstein-Format mit dieser Antenne, die man so zweimal knicken konnte, so falten konnte. Das war das Pocky. Genau, das Pocky, das war das Pocky. Das war dann eher so...
Aber macht mal weiter.
Das sind 10-Netz-Telefone.
Das war so das erste wirklich tolle Mobilfunk.
Das war auch relativ süß. 10-Netz, Pocky, da hab ich noch mit Lego gespielt. Und zwar haben wir das am besten importiert.
Und die Nerds hatten sowas natürlich. Da gibt es ja auch diese schöne Geschichte von Andy.
Der, der irgendwie damals noch als Anfang 20 oder so, oder ein bisschen jünger, zwischen Hamburg und Berlin auch mal getrempt ist und dann irgendwann auch mal mit einem Mercedes-Fahrer gefahren ist.
Vollausstattung, Autotelefon.
Autotelefon, alles mögliche.
Ich hab alles. Und dann fahren sie über die Autobahn und auf einmal macht es Klingelingeling und der Typ greift zu seinem Autotelefon Hallo und es macht Klingelingeling. Und Andi greift irgendwie in seine Plastiktüte rein oder in seine zerstörende Tasche und holt halt irgendwie dieses Porti raus und Hallo und fängt an zu telefonieren. Und dessen Gesicht hätte ich immer gerne gesehen. Aber auch das ist wieder so ein Living The Future. Der wusste wahrscheinlich zu dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht, dass man auch ohne Auto telefonieren kann.
So Mobiltelefone sind schon eine ziemlich solide Technologie und da kann man eigentlich auch immer noch ganz gut begründen, wozu man es braucht. Also das ist ja auch mal so eine Sache bei diesen Gadgets, wo den Leute ja schön, aber wozu brauchst du denn das? So und dann muss man schon sich immer irgendwie eine Geschichte ausdenken. Es könnte ja vielleicht und wenn ich denn einsam im Wald stehe und plötzlich das Unwetter kommt oder so.
Aber das ist doch genau das Ding, wo ich eben schon, als du das erwähnt hast, Nerds brauchen das nicht zu brauchen. Die brauchen nur ein Gefühl dafür zu haben, dass das schon irgendeinen Nutzen haben wird. Als ich an mein allererstes Computererlebnis, wo ich so entflammt wurde, war halt auch so der Typ im Laden, der mir irgendwie diesen Rechner gezeigt hat, tippte halt so ein paar Zeilen Code ein und es liefen halt tausend sinnlose Zeichen über den Bildschirm vollkommen sinnfrei und ich dachte mir nur so, das ist es, so, das muss ich jetzt unbedingt sofort lernen. Aber ich kann nicht erklären, dass ich jetzt irgendwie irgendeinen Nutzen da drin gesehen hätte.
Das war pure Faszination.
Die beiden Argumentationen sind glaube ich ziemlich auf der gleichen Linie. Nerds brauchen keinen Anlass oder keinen Grund, jetzt irgendwas dringend erfinden zu müssen, dass man die Brauseflasche einfacher aufmachen kann. Gar nicht. Aber um es sozusagen flächendeckend als technische Revolution in die Welt zu tragen und die Bevölkerung sagt, stimmt, wieso haben wir eigentlich die Räder an unserem Holzkahn früher viereckig gemacht? Rund geht's viel einfacher. Dazu musst du sozusagen ihnen erklären, dass es einen praktischen Nutzen hat, eine Vereinfachung, eine Unkompliziertheit, eine Erleichterung ihres Lebens. Oder?
Ja, hast du recht. Aber Nerds machen häufig ziemlich schlechte Produkte, muss ich feststellen.
Ja, deswegen gibt es ja dann wiederum nicht über das, wie kann man das gebrauchen, sich darüber Gedanken machen, sondern das ist technisch machbar.
Ja, aber es ist doch an sich toll. Also was es für tolle Feature hat, aber dass man dann die nicht anwenden kann, ist eine andere Sache.
Aber was wäre die Welt langweilig, wenn Nerds sowas nicht erfinden würden? Stichwort Blinkenlights.
Das stimmt schon. Blinkenlights.
Womit wir ganz langsam, und die Kurve ist schwer zu sehen, aber ich hab versucht, sie zu kriegen, womit wir ganz langsam zum Kongress kommen.
Von der Location her sind wir nah dran.
Oh nein, das war ja jetzt aber eine Kurve. Oder? Ja, du spielst auf das Motto an. Oder vielleicht spielst du nicht auf das Motto an.
Vielleicht erst mal auf die Veranstaltung.
Genau. Also es ist ja wieder Kongress. Haha, das sagen wir immer im November. Ist bald mal wieder Kongress. Der 24. Chaos Communication Kongress vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember 2007, wie gehabt am WCC, Berliner Kongresscenter, also am Alexanderplatz, Mütten in Berlin.
Das ist da zwischen Alexa und da, wo die Nadel ist. Der Kulturpickel.
Genau. Und ja, der findet statt, wie immer, mit großem Tamtam und steht dieses Jahr unter dem Titel Volldampf voraus. Ein sehr nach vorne blickender und auch gleichzeitig nach hinten blickender Titel, denn es gibt so, naja, es gibt da so ein schönes Sinnbild, was herangezogen wurde, nämlich das Sinnbild des Steampunks. Sagt ihr das was?
Nee.
Steampunk, das ist so, naja, wie soll man das nennen? So eine kulturelle Bewegung, dass Leute Hightech in viktorianische Kleider gießen. Da hast du dann so Laptops mit messigen Beschlägen und Steampunk sagt ja auch schon, wo es hingeht. Es ist im Prinzip so diese Wiederauferstehung der Dampfmaschine.
Die allerdings mit Hybridantrieb und Brennstoffzelle funktioniert.
Ja, ne oder die einfach nur eine Dampfmaschine ist. Also das Sinnbild, was da bemüht wird.
Das ist aber auch besonders schön dann. Also es geht auch vor allem um Ästhetik dabei natürlich. Es geht nicht so sehr um die Funktion, sondern es geht einfach darum, irgendwie Hightech irgendwie auch schön ästhetisch zu verpacken. Also dieser wirkliche Fetisch dabei ist einfach sehr detailreich, diesen alten Look hinzubekommen.
Genau, aber beim Kongress geht es natürlich eigentlich um was anderes. Der Kongress blickt ja immer auf Technik und Gesellschaft, wie wir das generell tun, und beim Kongress natürlich dann nochmal ganz gezielt. Und das Motto lädt sozusagen ein zum Vergleich dieser beiden industriellen Revolutionen, nämlich der ursprünglichen, die eben ausgelöst unter anderem und vor allem durch die Dampfmaschine, die einfach sämtliche Produktionsprozesse verändert hat, die das Transportwesen verändert hat. Auf einmal gab es Lokomotiven, die einfach unglaublich schwere Lasten von A nach B fuhren konnten. Handel, Produktion, alles war halt komplett dadurch verändert und vor allem auch die Kommunikation, weil die Leute sich eben bewegen konnten und weil man Güter verschicken konnte. Und wir spulen nach vorne. Jetzt haben wir die digitale Revolution, das Informationszeitalter und wieder geschieht eigentlich genau das Gleiche. Auf einmal sind Güter virtuell und Reisen über Datennetze und Dienstleistungen können von irgendwo angeboten werden und das ganze Verhältnis, das gewohnte von Raum und Zeit und von Orten gerät eben aus den Fugen. Und das ist so ein bisschen der Spielball, wo da jetzt beim Kongress thematisch mit rangegangen wird. Ansonsten gibt es natürlich das übliche, die übliche Bandbreite von Vorträgen, technisches, von Security, Programmierung, alles Mögliche, aber auch nicht technisches, kulturelle Highlights, gibt lustige Veranstaltungen und ich bin ja organisatorisch nicht eingebunden, aber das, was ich bisher gehört habe, das sieht super aus und das Programm ist auch schon online.
Und da gibt es eine Liste, wo ich mir angucken kann, wer was machen, damit ich nicht 12 Stunden am Tag da rum sitze und das muss ich auch nicht tun.
Aber es gibt einen Fahrplan, das ist so heiß bei uns, genau, und man muss mal sagen, es ist eine Veranstaltung, da kommen so 2.000 bis 3.000 Leute, das wird also schon ganz schön voll da, ganz schön kuschelig. 4.000 Leute. 4.000 mittlerweile, also insgesamt ja. Und ja, man muss jetzt nicht eigentlich kein Vorwissen mitbringen, es gibt natürlich bestimmte Sachen, die sind jetzt sehr speziell, aber wir bemühen uns auch immer die Bandbreite so zu halten, dass auch Leute, die jetzt nicht die Technik Nerds sind, sondern sich irgendwie nur dieser Sache so ein bisschen hingezogen fühlen, sich da auch wohlfühlen.
Ja und der Kongress ist vor allem echt großer Spaß.
Es ist eine Wohlfühlveranstaltung.
Muss man einfach betonen, es ist einfach fun. Events.ccc.de ist unser Blog zu dem Thema Veranstaltung und insbesondere natürlich jetzt im Kongress. Dort findet man eigentlich alles, was man wissen muss, allerdings.
Und wenn du glaubst, dass du jetzt alle Fragen geklärt hättest, beziehungsweise alle Informationen weitergegeben hättest, dann hätte sich jetzt Nico auf dich.
Ja und zwar, ach, die Fragestellen.
Ja und zwar, ich hab mal vor einer Weile gesehen im Internet so ein schönes Video.
Ihr hattet bei einem eurer Treffen einen Gastredner da und zwar war das irgendwie ein Staatsanwalt, der hat einen Vortrag gehalten zu Hausdurchsuchungen.
Oh ja, der Udo Vetter.
Das war kein Staatsanwalt, das ist ein Rechtsanwalt.
Na oder genau Rechtsanwalt. Auf jeden Fall war das ziemlich lustig.
Das ist der vom vom LawBlock.
Genau, vom LawBlock. Sie haben das Recht zu schweigen, heißt der Vortrag und war mit Abstand der populärste des gesamten Kongresses.
Ja, es war sehr lustig, was er da alles gesagt hat, was sie da alles für Tricks angewandt haben und so weiter. Auf jeden Fall wollte ich euch fragen, ob ihr dieses Jahr auch wieder Gastredner habt, wenn ja, welcher und so weiter.
Ja, schaut doch mal auf events.ccc.de ohnehin.
Also events.ccc.de, der letzte Blockeintrag, zeigt direkt auf den Fahrplan. Die Uhr ist ein bisschen länger. Können wir jetzt hier nicht zusammenfassen, aber ich kann auch schon mal ankündigen, dass es in den nächsten Tagen, in den nächsten zehn Tagen wird es einen Podcast bei Chaos Radio Express geben, also dem Chaos Radio mit ohne Fritz. Und dort gibt es ein Preview für den 24C3. Das heißt, da wird auch so inhaltlich, was so läuft, alles zur Sprache kommen.
Sehr schön. Ja, dann bedanke ich mich für die Auskunft.
Gerne.
Gerne. Ich würde ja jetzt gerne Musik spielen. Hatten wir nämlich beim letzten Mal schon und da gab es einen Haufen nachfragen, was ist das denn gewesen. Der Typ heißt Pete Green mit I haven't got a MySpace because MySpace fucking sucks. Es wird interessant sein zu erfahren, wie nach uns kommende Generationen diese Welt der Social Networking in Verbindung stehenden Websites Xingvz und wie sie alle heißen, das dann sehen werden und sich Geschichten erzählen werden, sagen, guck sie dir an, der Homosapiens damals, die haben sich irgendwie mit ihren Freunden getroffen, obwohl sie ihre Freunde niemals gesehen haben. Komische, merkwürdige Welt. Bringen wir auch noch ein Stück von der Rehkeule mit. Wahrscheinlich wird eine Unterhaltung dann genauso laufen.
Möglich, ja.
Aber darüber werden wir im Chaosradio nicht mehr reden, zumindest nicht mehr in diesem Jahr und nicht mehr heute, denn das Thema ist ein ganz anderes. Living with the future.
Living the future. Mit der Zukunft müssen wir immer leben, aber sie leben selber, das ist natürlich echt ein Unterschied. Wir haben ja gestern im Club auch noch mal ein bisschen rumgefragt, so nach Geschichten, was denn so die Leute so als Living the Future, ich bin echt erstaunt, dass jeder eigentlich sofort was auszugraben hat. Was ich auch noch total cool fand, ist so die Sache mit diesen Telefonbuch-CDs. Irgendwann kamen auch diese Telefonbuch-CDs raus mit so Windows-Gliedern und so weiter. Als die Dinger auf dem Markt waren, haben sich natürlich die Hacker sofort diese Dinger geschnappt und irgendwie versucht, da diese Datenbank-Formate auseinanderzuschneidern und dann dauerte es nicht lange und man konnte halt...
Genau, der Trick war, man konnte natürlich nur Namen eingeben und dann die Telefonnummer dazu, aber man konnte nicht die Telefonnummer eingeben und dann den Namen und die Adresse dazu bekommen. Die Inverssuche, wie es heißt. Genau. Ja und so war es dann auch, wie wir dann mit unseren großen, dicken, zähnetzportablen Telefonen am Bahnhof Zoo standen, nämlich abends, wo die zweite Hand, Kleine Anzeigenblatt, abends dann schon vor Abend rauskam. Ein armer Händler, der da stand und irgendwie 30, 40 Leute stürzten sich auf ihn und rissen ihm diese Zeitung außer Hand. Wir saßen dann da im Auto mit unseren komischen Telefonen und einem alten Laptop, der irgendwie einen riesen Akku mit sich schleppte, wo dann diese einmal umsortierte Telefonbuch-CD drauf war. Das heißt, wir wussten dann auch schon sofort, wo die Leute waren und haben dann teilweise gar nicht mehr die Mühe gemacht, da irgendwie anzurufen, sondern sind dann direkt da vorbeigefahren.
Was wolltet ihr denn kaufen?
Leute, glaube ich, alte Autos oder so, also zum ja, ein bisschen reparieren, aufhübschen, dann wieder verkaufen. Oder wir haben auch alte Telefon-Teile gesucht, gerade Mobiltelefone, wo wir dann aus zwei Stück wieder eins gemacht haben und so was.
Das heißt, ihr habt die Telefonnummer angenommen und nichts anderes stand in der Anzeige? So nach dem Motto Verkaufe, altes Auto, Telefonnummer, hm hm hm.
Genau, Telefonnummer in den Computer eingeben, Adresse zack gleich auf den Weg hingefahren, vielleicht nochmal Anstandszeiten vorher angerufen, vielleicht auch nicht und gleich schon mal irgendwie als Erster da gewesen, zehn Minuten nachdem irgendwie diese Anzeigen zuerst ausfielen. Welches Jahr? Wann waren diese großen Zehnetze Telefone? Das muss so, wann ist die GSM eingeführt worden?
Woher kamen denn diese Telefonbuch-CDs denn raus?
Kurz nach der Christenverfolgung.
Zehn Jahre? Jetzt geht das halt auch ohne sowas. Mit Internet. Das ist doch Zukunft, oder? Ich finde, das ist total zu.
Es gibt, also jeder hat natürlich für sich so einen Moment, wo man so die Glühbirne über dem Kopf aufgehen sieht. Wie die Geschichte, wo Papa sagt, du mit deinem komischen Computer blockierst dir die Telefonleitung. Zeig mir doch mal, was die Büchse kann. Also alles raus, was du willst.
Um nochmal auf den Kongress zu kommen. Also wenn man irgendwie auf so eine Momente, wie wir sie hier schildern, steht, dann muss man echt zum Kongress kommen.
Wenn man das zwölf Stunden am Tag haben will.
Dann kriegt man das nämlich echt am laufenden Meter. Ich meine auch sicherlich auf ein paar anderen Veranstaltungen, aber sicherlich nirgendwo so dicht wie auf dem Kongress. Weil da gibt es immer wieder so Sachen, da klappt mir auch irgendwie so, klappt mir echt die Kinnlade runter.
Vor allem, mit welcher Selbstverständlichkeit so Leute denn irgendwie hier Technik rumschrauben und da basteln und löten und tun?
Hier dieser verrückte Brite, der irgendwie, der ist ja noch gleich, verdammt, ich komm jetzt nicht drauf, der diese Tor-Server analysiert hat. Der hat dann irgendwie, der hat so die Tor-Daten...
Das ist Anonymisierung.
Genau, das ist Anonymisierung. Das heißt, Rechner versuchen komplett anonym zu sein. Dann hat er da irgendwie aus der Ferne gelauscht und irgendwie nur so die Zeitstempel in den Datenpaketen, die da rauskamen, genommen. Und dann hat er das irgendwie zurückführen können, da drauf, wann dort, wo der Computer steht, die Sonne auf und unter ging. Weil es halt tagsüber wärmer ist und sich die Computer ausdehnen und die Zeit läuft dann anders als nachts. Und dann kann er halt auch sehen, wann geht's auf und zu und dann weiß er auch ganz genau, wo die sind auf dem Planeten. Man kann ja wirklich sagen, der ist in der Schweiz, weil er irgendwie Longitude und Latitude einfach da rausrechnen kann. Das ist einfach mal geile Scheiße. So wirklich einfach nur mathematisch da so ranzugehen, find ich super. Ist toll.
Und sowas ist alles beim Kongress zu finden. Ja, sowas ist alles beim Kongress in Berlin.
Genau, weil es so schön ist.
chaosradio.ccc.de, da gibt es auch die Podcasts von Chaos Radio Express.
Richtig.
Und Chaos TV und das Zielkritik, da gibt es auch eine ganze Menge Sachen, da solltet ihr dann mal ein bisschen rumstapfeln.
Und dann ein Wiki zum Mitmachen bei den Sendungen.
Genau, das Blog möchte ich euch nochmal besonders ans Herz legen, weil wir das erst vor kurzem aufgemacht haben und das noch nicht so viele Leute kennen. Wir sind ja immer so ein bisschen zu faul, euch rechtzeitig Mails schicken vor der Sendung, weil wir immer zu was weiß ich, verpeilt oder beschäftigt sind. Eines von beiden könnt ihr euch aussuchen. Aber das Blog ist etwas einfacher zu führen und zu pflegen. Und deswegen tun wir das auch. Und da kann man halt auch zur Sendung, auch zu dieser, kommentieren. Oder eben auch gleich Nützliches in die Mitmachseite zu dieser Chaosradio Sendung eintragen im Wiki. wiki.chaosradio.ccc.de und blog.chaosradio.ccc.de Jetzt hab ich es genug gesagt, oder?
Jetzt haben wir es genug gesagt. Falls ihr noch weitere Fragen habt, schickt eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de Ich glaube so oft und in solcher Intensität haben wir lange nicht die ganzen Adressen und Sollen wir sie nicht vielleicht nochmal? Was wir jetzt noch sagen ist, dass es uns extrem viel Spaß gemacht hat heute. Chaosradio 130 vielen vielen Dank. Das nächste Chaosradio kommt im Januar.
Genau, wir machen die Kongresspause.
Genau, denn das letzte beim eigentlich tonusmäßigen Dezember Chaosradio fandet ihr ja der Kongress statt, deswegen gibt es da kein Chaosradio.
Und das nächste Chaosradio Express kommt noch diese Woche und es wird cool.
Was jetzt noch kommt ist der Kollege Martin Petershoff mit fantastischer handausgesuchter Musik. Sowas ist mittlerweile selten im Radio, deswegen euch viel Spaß in dieser Sendung. Wir sagen Tschüss. Und nicht irgendwie gleich Strom und Wechselstrom verwechseln. Wollen wir jetzt nochmal diese Spex nochmal spielen oder wollen wir was anderes spielen?
Welches andere?
Wir spielen jetzt nochmal Spex.
Nochmal das gleiche?
Volle Kanone.
Ist doch langweilig. Cool, ach doch.